i think i saw someone on social media
get a tattoo of your face on their body
which is weird
um it's been overwhelming um and surreal
johnny depp's lawyer camille vasquez is
embracing her newfound fame following
the actor's victory in his defamation
lawsuit against amber hurd he promised
you you would never see his eyes again
isn't that true you had all of the seven
million dollars
for 13 months before mr depp sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities who was the real monster in
this relationship miss heard
lives in johnny half of johnny yeah it
was that tough cross-examination that
made camille a breakout star and now
she's telling today's savannah guthrie
how she's feeling all about her new
celebrity status not since oj perhaps
has the trial been so closely watched
and the lawyers become famous people in
their own right what has that been like
for you particularly you camille it's
been overwhelming um and surreal but to
the extent that i can encourage young
women to stay in school and maybe
inspire them to
pursue a legal career then it's all
worth it oh and it's been so worth it
for her because camille's just scored a
promotion to partner at brown rudnick
well i understand you got a promotion
yesterday to partner
well-deserved i was going to say about
time another partner right the orange
county-based law firm gave her nothing
but praise in their statement camille's
performance during the johnny depp trial
proved to the world that she was ready
to take this next step now we are
incredibly proud of her and look forward
to what she will accomplish as our
newest partner and camille she's pumped
on her new swanky job title i'm
delighted that brown rudnick has given
me its full vote of confidence by having
me join the partnership
all right mr foreperson is this the
verdict of the jury
all right is it unanimous
thank you sir camille's new role comes
nearly a week after a jury decided amber
did in fact defame johnny awarding him
15 million dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages
[Music]
following johnny's big win camille
celebrated outside the courthouse
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning that the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence
we are grateful so grateful to the jury
for their careful deliberation
to the judge and the court staff who
have devoted an enormous amount of time
and resources towards this case and now
camille and her legal teammate ben chu
are revealing how johnny's doing now
that it's all over i was speaking with
another friend of ours a mutual friend
of johnny's and ours and he said i
haven't seen johnny smile like that in
six years the weight of the world is off
of his shoulders he's got his life back
[Music]
you